Dave you are always so tough when it
comes to our kids living with us our
parents living with us or us moving in
with our parents or whatever you believe
in tough love
now I just believe in love and love says
I have to tell you what is best for you
and what is best for them love real love
does not go along with crazy real love
does not endorse it because I don't have
the strength to stand up and say no I
don't think this is a good idea for you
so here let's just have a little bit of
help here I have no trouble with helping
your parents and letting them move in I
have no trouble with your grown kid
coming back home and living with you for
a period of time we all should be a
safety net for each other what we don't
want to be is a hammock there's a
difference in a safety net and a hammock
a safety net is uncomfortable a hammock
is you live in your mother's basement
till you're 38 and you don't have a life
a hammock is your mother is still
grieving over something and she spins
like she's in Congress and no one can
tell her anything and so you're gonna
have her move in with you and she's
gonna continue her version of mental
illness with her spending disorder
because she won't deal with reality that
is not good for her it is not good for
your 38 year old to live in your
basement still so a couple rules a
couple things if you want to really help
a family member not just in able them
not just give a drunk a drink if someone
is going to move in with you
and you're doing that to help them in
quotes you see the air quotes help them
write you want to help them then let's
really help them
what does real help look like real help
causes them to be better as a result of
your help when you give a drunk a drink
they're not better you've enabled them
they feel better they like you but
there's still a drunk and you caused
them to still be a drunk because you
gave a drunk a drink that is not love
that's quite the opposite of love why
would you do that to someone that you
say you love and so if you're 28 year
old has gone through a divorce and has a
kid and whatever or doesn't have a kid
and they need a safe place to heal a
little bit and they come in out of the
cold and they're gonna move in with you
for a little while to get back on their
feet to get their emotional chops under
them to get their spiritual chops back
onto them get their career going maybe
get some debts paid off and be able to
start again there's nothing wrong with
that at all there's nothing wrong with
your elderly parents who are struggling
moving in with you and you helping to
take care of them there's you know that
glass guy that calls it's not a bad
thing the bad thing is you need to put
requirements on them that help them heal
so that they can leave in other words
should I charge my my 24 year old rent
no now you shouldn't charge them rent
you should throw them out as soon as
possible well that's a no-no really I
mean what is the best thing for a 24
year old to have the dignity of being a
freakin adult buy your own groceries and
pay your own light bill that is dignity
the ability to produce in the
marketplace leave the cave kill
something and drag at home
there is tremendous emotional and
physical and relational benefit so help
them become that kind of an adult and so
if they're gonna live with you for the
next six months in preparation for you
to kick them out then there's two things
we're gonna do one is we're gonna give
you a deadline so that last guy mom and
dad you can move in with us for six
months you can move in with us for one
year during that year there will be no
rent charged except you will do these
things that are good for you in lieu of
rent instead of rent so instead of
paying me rent you are going to
Financial Peace University every class
you are going to turn in a written
budget that I see and that you stick to
every month while you're here you are
going to see a financial coach you're
going to sell the car that you can't
afford and you are going to heal this
thing that in 75 years inside of you has
never been right and it's time for it to
be right that is really loving them but
if you look at them and say you can't
afford this car you need to sell it and
they go oh that's non-negotiable they
don't need to move in with you because
they're not willing to deal with their
crap the crap that's inside their mental
health or lack thereof and so you look
at your 24 year old and you say six
months from today we're gonna move your
little butt into an apartment during the
next six months we're not going to
charge you a dime but during the next
six months you're going to Financial
Peace University you're going to be on a
written budget I'm gonna see a written
budget every month you're gonna start
saving a percentage of what you give if
you live under our roof we go to church
on Sunday and we do not party till 3:00
in the morning and snort cocaine if
you're under my roof that's what you do
if you don't wanna live under my roof
you get to choose
if you're under my roof that's what you
do because I own that freaking place
that that's that's a controllable those
four walls are mine and people that are
in those four walls are gonna behave by
my value system or they don't get to be
in those four walls why you're a control
freak dadgum right dadgum right I'm a
control freak I control the
controllables the variables in my life
that caused me to be successful the
variables in your life that caused you
to be successful and partying all night
and snorting cocaine and coming in at 3
o'clock in the morning and not having a
spiritual walk and not having a job and
not saving money and not being generous
are controllable variables that are
going to cause you to win or not win and
I love you so much I'm going to make you
do what is good for you or you gotta be
somewhere else cuz I'm not gonna
participate in your crazy that's whole
thing that's that's the difference in
enabling and loving someone well
enablers are sweet people but they're
weak they don't love well
[Music]